now a team of royal marine commandos
have just completed a row from the
brooklyn bridge in new york to tower
bridge this is to raise awareness of the
plastic in our oceans the expedition was
due to begin in may 2020 but obviously
because the pandemic it had to be
postponed and this is day 72
of their row and here they are in
central london a few moments ago just
about to go
under tower bridge to complete
that row it's being described as one of
the most dangerous rows there is it's
never been done before um a couple of
the marines on board are lanka shellads
from accrington and chorley uh they've
been rowing with their team for
000 miles
um matt mason from accrington and jordan
swift from chorley a part of this
four-man ocean revival team uh they're
raising money for two charities for the
royal marines
family charity
and for um an ocean charity as well uh
they've raised over 20 000 pounds that
ocean charity um and they're doing it to
highlight the amount of plastic in the
oceans they've just arrived you can see
them coming under the bridge there
lighting their flares
and waving to those who have come
to greet them as i said uh it's been
dubbed the world's most dangerous row um
following the same route as the doomed
titanic i'm informed but fortunately a
better outcome for those lads they're
celebrating they're
still going i'd have put those ores down
a little while ago after crossing that
bridge but they're obviously full of
excitement and adrenaline having crossed
that finish line i we'll have more on
that on the daily climate show this
evening uh they'll be talking about why
they wanted to make this expedition
never been done before and as i said
dubbed one of the world's most dangerous
roads from new york to london well done
to them